Luna Lovegood is practically a Disney
character as it is she's a free spirit
who marches to the beat of Her Own Drum
and if that isn't Disney princess
material then we don't know what is
Ivana Lynch even praised this fan art of
a disney-fied version of Luna by mad
Boogie Creations to her Instagram page
according to her it really captures
Luna's soul and by that she meant her
dreaminess Whimsy curiosity Serenity and
depth and we can see it too Ivana just
look at those large eyes exactly like
Anna and Elsa's from Frozen you also get
a sense of Luna's total uniqueness in
this picture with her Specter specs on
top of her head